I am sorry you could get it sooner I'm
not good I'm like uh Jada pinkett-smith
in tears speaking with our Kelly accuser
at Lisa Van Alen we didn't expect it to
be this powerful this impactful like
because you know I came out in 2008 and
nobody hear me yeah it's awesome yeah it
takes practice to have those difficult
conversations with kindness and
consideration the more that we can bring
these difficult subjects to light and
talk about it the more we can purify
these subjects
Lisa joined Jada Jada's mom Adrienne and
daughter Willow for an emotional
conversation on read table talk
following the release of lifetime's
docu-series surviving r.kelly
which follows the stories of women who
allege the singer abused them and kept
them against their will our Kelly has
denied the allegations and has
threatened to sue life time over the
series Lisa explained why it was so
important for her to share her story
there was a me before me too because in
2008 there weren't any movement you know
nobody else was talking about it so and
I came out you know hoping that I could
help the victims
Lisa's 16 year old daughter later joined
the group she teared up too scary up
people are crazy
yeah earlier in the show Jada Adrienne
and Willow discussed the lifetime series
and explained why it was so important
for them to watch together as a family
man how complicit exactly we all have
been that really broke my heart like to
really think about we we ignored it Jada
even shared that the series made her
think back to a time when she says she
was in an unhealthy relationship I've
been addicted to that cycle of knowing
that this person is not treating me well
but then you get solo and then he comes
in with his sweetness
and you're like Oh back in April et was
first to visit the read table it is
amazing to be here at the red tape a lot
happens at the red tip explain to me
what it's all about well the red table
is a place of testimony you know and a
place where we get to share our story
share our experiences and get to really
talk and spill our truth in a very raw
way just talking about different
discussions like one of them is sex and
one of them is lost and another we're
doing one about misogyny of music right
so different topics that concern us but
we get to speak about it from three
different generations through the lens
of three different generations
[Music]